عتمه واسعه النطاق تسيطر على الولايات
المتحده طبعا مع استمرار العاصفه غير
المسبوقه ظروف شتاء قاسيه وثلوج ايضا اودت
بحياتي 50 شخصا على الاقل حتى هذه اللحظه
تركت عشرات الالاف من المنازل دون كهرباء
ودونا مياه في مدن متفرقه بافلو مثلا
الواقعه غرب نيويوركيا واحده من اكثر
المدن المتضرره من هذه العاصفه الثلجيه
التي اطلق عليها عاصفه القرن الالاف من
سكانها تقطعت بهم السبل فيما عالق اخرون
في منازل مغطاه بانجرافات شديده العلوم
قدرت بسته اقدام طبعا هذه العاصفه التي
اخلت سماء الولايات المتحده من الطائرات
وايضا عطلت الالاف من الرحلات الداخليه
وايضا الدوليه فتحت النقاش مجددا حول
التغير المناخي وحول دوره في حدوث الظواهر
المناخيه القصوى
نطاق العاصفه غير مسبوق تقريبا امتد من
منطقه البحيرات العظمى قرب كندا الى ريو
غراندي على طول الحدود مع المكسيك بحسب
خبراء فان التغير المناخي يسرع من وتيره
حدوث العوامل المناخيه المتشدده محدرين من
ان الامر لا يقتصر على شتاء قارس او عواصف
وفيضانات بل ستزيد هذه العوامل في كل فصول
السنه ما يشمله ذلك من حدوث على سبيل
المثال حرائق وايضا جفاف اضافه طبعا الى
الفيضانات والعواصف اكد خبراء انو وتيره
حصول مثل هذه العواصف كانت كل خمس سنوات
في السابق لكن التغيرات المناخيه
المتسارعه قد تؤدي لحدوثها مره او مرتين
خلال العام واحد
[موسيقى]